(rolls tongue)
- Almost got a little spit on you.
Alright, my first line.
(rolls tongue)
I want to say Ride Along, I think?
(electronic buzzing)
Damn it, it's that part
on the plane Kevin.
I'm getting old, that was Soul Plane.
God dammit.
Alright.
A little wet, but I still look good.
Think Like a Man.
(electronic buzzing)
God dammit!
What?
Who wrote these?
I'm a stop you right there.
I never said I was in.
In fact, I expressly remember
saying that I was out.
Central Intelligence.
(bell dings)
Central Intelligence, alright, that's one.
You know what they got in Afghanistan?
Land mines.
Boom, you got no legs.
Boom!
You got no legs.
Ride Along.
(bell dings)
Yeah look, ain't nobody calling
to fight with you right now.
Ain't nobody calling to
fight with you right now.
Think Like a Man.
(bell dings)
(laughs)
Alright, check this out.
You're throwing way too
many big words at me.
Because I don't understand 'em.
So I'm gonna take that as disrespect.
Oh, this is one of the
ones that popped me.
This is 40-Year-Old Virgin.
(bell dings)
That's right.
You making me mad, mother fucker.
There's only two movies that
I said mother fucker in.
This is Get Hard.
(bell dings)
Yep.
We're very scattered today.
This type of thing almost never happens.
Death at a Funeral.
(bell dings)
(laughs)
Liberated forever!
Domesticated never!
Secret Life of Pets.
(bell dings)
Hey, I'm uh, sorry about your wife.
This is either Get Hard
or it's Think Like a Man.
I'm a go Get Hard.
Get Hard?
(electronic buzzing)
I knew it, I knew it wasn't.
I felt that one.
Did you see that?
I did the thing.
Did you see that, I did the thing.
Oh, Central Intelligence.
(bell dings)
I did the thing, that's this.
I did a lot of movies guys.
Cause you ate the cake.
Did I do What's Love Got to Do With It?
Cause you ate the cake?
About Last Night.
(electronic buzzing)
I only had three lines in that movie,
that's why I didn't know this.
I'm not a barbarian.
He keeps clenching,
I can't make an insertion, what?
(laughs)
He keeps clenching?
I can't make an,
oh, oh.
Little Fockers,
(bell dings)
that's what it was.
I was the nurse.
What you doing in the trunk?
What you doing in the damn trunk?
Seriously Funny?
(electronic buzzing)
Where the fuck am I at?
I see all these muscle cars,
but I don't see no muscle.
That's Ride Along 2.
(bell dings)
I got five wrong?
That's not bad.
All the rest of 'em right.
This is Kevin Hart.